ragazzi bentornati una nuova puntata di
cucina buttata quarantena edition allora
sono a casa per la prima volta non
abbiamo passato la mezzanotte quindi
cucinerà un orario decente sono le dieci
e mezza dei dieci sempre un po tardi
oggi uno è venuta un'idea pazzesca
perché in questi giorni scusate io nel
frattempo pulisco l'obiettivo dicevo in
questi giorni ho riflettuto molto su
quale ricetta suggerirvi questa domenica
e devo dire che tra le varie ricette le
quali pensato ce n'è uno in particolare
che io adoro che non mi faccio un sacco
di tempo quindi in realtà sta unendo la
mia cena in cucina buttata così che poi
proprio bagno di gusto perché
solitamente magno vergogna quindi mentre
perdo le calorie che andrà poi a
implementare perché questa qui ragazzi è
una roba di un porco pazzesco
vi dico già che faremo un piatto che è
un secondo un secondo che a che vedere
col collo la prima cosa che mi viene in
mente quando parlo di pollo è ovviamente
una scelta di una grandissima chef
elisabetta canalis
partendo dal presupposto che a me
elisabetta canalis con molta molta
simpatia e per quanti non possa essere
interessato all'articolo la reputo
comunque una delle poche donne di
spettacolo essere bellissima autoironica
e super super intelligente posso dire
spero senza farla arrabbiare che a
cucinare per quello che so non è che sia
proprio un drago quindi è perfetta per
questo tipo di format pollo alla
elisabetta canalis
allora leggo dal sito in un'intervista
che uscita molto tempo fa pollo alla
piastra alla elisabetta canalis che uno
si chiede che cosa avrà di diverso il
pollo alla piastra di elisabetta canalis
da qualsiasi altro pollo e un pochino
che cosa dicono prendete una fetta di
petto di pollo e mettetela su una
piastra o su una padella bella calda
quando il colore della carne diventa
bianco la pietanza è pronta siamo seri
di pettino mio siamo seri sedin quando
il colore della carne diventa bianco
alla pietanza è pronta anche già detto
io non farò un pollo alla piastra di
elisabetta canalis ma fare una cosa
ancora migliore farò un pollo alla uil
bush che è croccante ora è una ricetta
che esiste un mio amico che è antonio di
back off dell'ultima stagione mi ha
parlato di questa ricetta è
effettivamente una ricetta che ho già in
passato facevo solo che lui la fa con
una variante che vi dirò alla fine ecco
perché con enorme orgoglio che vi posso
dire che fosse arrivato il momento di
metterlo in cucina e farvi volare
leggete il mio labiale volare o mangiare
www guardate che carine ciò non è amica
che mi ha mandato una tastiera che non
ci sentiamo in un sacco e 2 miche mano
mandato l'uovo no sponsored non
sponsored quindi non sponsor ton non lo
comprate non lo comprate per fare o di
rho si accende no per fare il pollo
croccante alla uil bus avremo bisogno di
bocconcini di pollo olio per friggere
uova farina patatine fritte cat mobile
toglie una una via verso la pa cliccando
qui secondo me sono le patatine migliori
mostrare quello che provo italcementi
pure cosa avete bisogno di paprika
calcolate che questa ricetta della quali
sono io questa farfallina in mente il
nome davvero questa ricetta in realtà
esiste a me sono appropriato perché se
elisabetta può appropriarsi un po la
piastra che posso appropriarmi di un
polo croccante deco rubato a casa di
qualcuno e poi non l'ho mai letta né
sulla parte quindi stica faccio quello
che mi pare oggi anarchia oggi è così
tanto anarchia
magari non litio nemmeno a farvi vedere
subito una ricetta vi faccio vedere da
mille che ho dodici una delle forbici
una scopa e ricordarci quello che lo
stiamo facendo
manco a dirlo vi faccio vedere lei amore
della mia vita è uno specchio che ho
pagato un sacco di soldi di seletti che
secondo me è passo ogni centesimi
contagio è una specie di cannella con le
ciabatte semplicemente infiammabile per
prima cosa prepariamo gli ingredienti
prendiamo un sacchetto e cheever siamo
dentro un po di patatine
a questo punto ragazzi con molta molta
delicatezza andiamo a pestarle perfette
consentono bebe vio mentre le a critiche
pensate a tutte le persone che fanno
fatto male in vita vostra ti è nullo
delle medie chi è chi è chi è ottiene
rotto quando si rompe vuol dire che sono
pronte versate il vostro composto
all'interno della ciotola prendete il
sacchetto e buttatelo nella plastica
quindi passiamo alle prendiamole el e
apriamo all'interno una ciotola per il
ferito non è pure una di quelle cassette
ratp minuscolo salmonella 12 in
trent'anni a fa ste cose non passa
questo ovviamente un procedimento che va
fatto al passato non passano fa ok ce
l'ho fatto comodissimo quindi a questo
punto ne aggiungiamo a un altro
passiamo a sbatterle quando sbattete le
uova ricordatevi di metterci tutto
l'amore del mondo perché sono tra le
pochissime cose che in questo periodo
stanno tenendo sbattute quindi cercate
di tre anni un pochino di soddisfazione
sapere che cosa da allo standard
e guarda
stazione
sta bene
l uomo
ma che soddisfazione
da todi
un po come
vabbè l'aspetto nota bene fondamentale
che mi sa che si sbattono le uova si
spezzi la frusta quando si rompe la
frusta avete capito che le uova sono
pronte a questo punto molto importante
prendete la farina e l'ha versata e
all'interno di un contenitore di poco è
stata azionata da caffè perché la più
grande e purtroppo connesso a lavare
perché son qui una volta preparati i
loro tre metteteli da parte
con questo gesto via via via via via
e passiamo a lui al pollo enrico jam in
mente parliamo del pollo potete mettere
una musica molto molto tranquillizzante
tipo
un dettaglio importantissimo sul pon è
una cosa migliore sarebbe prendere già i
bocconcini io non li ho trovati
perché evidentemente in quarantena
sembrano tutti i bocconcini quindi ho
preso una cosa che si chiama offerta
speciale contro filetti di petto di
pollo io ora mi prenderò con delle
forbici andrò a fare i miei bocconcini
la cosa importante secondo me per il mio
gusto e che questi bocconcini siano
belli grossetti perché ti devono un
pochino soddisfare mondo dal morso se
sono troppo piccolini facevi prima
mangiarti nella ghiaia vi raccomando non
vi recate mai le dita quando la folla
mette rischiate si avventa moderna di
pollo hq una di quelle cose che tu devi
indovino immaginate che poi la piazza
per il coni per stranieri capire più o
meno prima sia legata al mondo ma a
questo punto armatevi di un piatto e
come potete ben immaginare prendete il
pollo lo mettete nella farina lo passate
nell'uovo
anzi è lui infine nelle patatine
sbriciola euro hanno sbagliato vedete le
patatine vede la paprica quella là
dentro a voi ea dio abbondo e poi
rischio ricominciamo prendete il pollo o
passate nella farina nell'uovo e poi
nelle patatine
infine lo mettiamo nel piatto facciamo
sì con tutti quanti meglio facciamo
questo passaggio è più alla fine vi
ritroverete con un piatto pazzesco è una
porcata ma è buonissima non so quante ne
possono andare a rivedere l'intero
procedimento fendi faremo un salto in
avanti nel tempo pensato che adesso non
posso fare perché le quali storico
importantissimo alla fine del
procedimento dovreste aver le dita così
non le catene perché rischia da sempre
la salmonella un piatto pieno di poletti
visti tengono già cotti quindi potrete
marmi lo sbatte e cucinarli e adesso
passiamo all assaggio che attraverso
mettete un replay ma è che cos'era
migliore allenatore che il suo era
comunque mettiamo in frigo a questo
punto i nostri bollette li lasciamo
riposare sarà più facile poi friggerle
nel frattempo mettiamo in ordine sto
delirio allora personalmente trovo che
questi poletti siano dico una delle cose
più goduriose che si possono fare in
assoluto non sono così difficili proprio
a prova di scemo se ce li a scorgere c'e
dunque vi consiglio solamente di non
mangiare viste patatine perché dalle
zone le sto buttando secondo me quel
suono possiamo risentire un secondo
è dovuto alle patatine ingerite con così
tanta voracità hanno tagliato il pollo
una mascherina non ve lo so dire
andiamo avanti anche qui perché credo in
me ne fotto mancati vedere come pulisco
la cucina a questo punto padella sul
fuoco assorbente no assorbente cosa
assorbente oddio santa comunque
prendiamo dal nostro frigo i nostri
bocconcini di pollo e andiamo a
friggerli dentro quella casella voglio
te the cat
io cerco sempre di metterli tutti in una
sola mandata perché mi annoio a morte
faremo non riuscirò a no no no non può
essere solo uno mi rimane fuori non ci
credo vabbè bravissimo carissimo grazie
al prezioso a questo punto non sono più
il gene se c'è una cosa pazzesca né
questo rumore che ha detto che su
youtube
non ci possono essere video se guardate
questo lasciatevi coinvolgere sentite
piacere che si fanno strada dritto pollo
freddo freddo paul nostri
io sono molto bravo a friggere la mia
regole per una buona frittura e olio non
troppo bollente perché sono visti vadano
le cose e pazienza ragazzi dovete avere
pazienza perché se iniziato a muovere le
cose quando ancora non sono belle e
croccanti vi si spaccano e non vengono
bene quindi pazienza io non ce l'ho io
gioco di girarli è la fissando poi non
accede di nel processo
un altro scottex perché secondo me
saranno pieni d'odio queste di s
ricordate che buoni cioè sembra di
potersi buonissimi per quanto il bello
l'olio come scopi e chiama guardarlo ma
passiamo tutto quanto sono fortemente
tipo a velocità che mi piace pensare
delle cose velocità
proviamoci le mani allora questo il
risultato
guardate quanto olio buttano quindi in
realtà un passaggio del panno che li
rende più sperperi che comunque più
asciutti e un'apertura asciutta e più
croccante e arrivato il momento
dell'assaggio da fare ma assolutamente
con le mani non si usano le posate
quindi sempre panchina fa tra fini e
dentro se non stanno poi deciderò nelle
arancia
tra parentesi se volete vedere come file
amuchina cliccate su questo link
non so se gianmarco la metterà ci ho
provato detto ciò come sempre vi invito
a iscrivervi a questo canale se c'è
sempre ma io non lo dico sempre
mettetevi un bel pollice in su anche di
più perché la quarantena si fa sentire e
fatemi sapere quale potrebbe essere una
ricetta che vorreste vedere in un futuro
cucina buttata quindi quando le ciance
rendere più facile la deglutizione di
quest'impegno nese tanta nola io uso un
matto della maionese matto di west ham e
ce n'era campioni per fortuna ci può
stare la palla abbiamo i miei sfondo
tutti e ci vediamo alla prossima puntata
ciao